Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome.
This is ActInf Lab Livestream number
52.0, and it is February 28, 2023.
Welcome to the active inference
institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active coherence.
You can find us at the links here on this
slide.
This is a recorded and an archived live
stream, so please provide feedback so we
can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams.
Head over active coherence.org if you
want to learn more and participate in
learning groups and projects at the
institute, including these live streams.
Well, we're here today to learn and
discuss the paper Geometric Methods for
Sampling, Optimization, Inference and
Adaptive Agents by Alessandro Barp
Lancelot Costa Guilherme Franca Karl
Friston Mark Girolami Michael Jordan
Grigorios A Pavliotis this video, like
all Zero videos, are is and introduction
for some of the ideas.
It is not a review or a final word, and
as we have joked before, it's more than
anything a call for help.
So if you're curious about these topics,
if you're knowledgeable about these
topics, we would really look forward to
you getting involved in the upcoming 52.1
and 52.2 discussions, as well as in an
ongoing basis to help us understand some
of the technical details.
This is going to get technical ant times
and certainly beyond the technicalities I
understand, though I am looking forward
to presenting them and it'll be great to
have those who have backgrounds of all
different types to come together and talk
about this awesome work.
Also, a big thanks to Ali and Candon for
the assistance, technical and moral.
During the preparations here in 52.0,
we're going to bring up some aims and
claims, read the abstract, look at the
roadmap and talk about the keywords, and
then we will walk through the paper with
an emphasis on the figures, formalisms
and key points.
In the coming weeks, we're going to be
discussing this paper with one or more
authors.
So, as usual, get in touch if you want to
participate or if it's after the fact,
you can still get involved.
We can start with an introduction or a
warm up.
I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California, and I'm tempted to say, just
totally honestly, I'm happy to get this
one over with, but that sounds a little
bit different than I might intended to
be.
I'm really excited to dive into this
work, which is going to be approaching
active inference from an angle that we
haven't necessarily highlighted on these
streams.
So I think it's going to be a fascinating
discussion.
It's going to run the gamut, span the gap
however you choose to see it, between
technical sophistication and intuition,
which is a great place to be.
So I've been really excited and motivated
to prepare, and I'm looking forward to
the dot zero we're doing right now and to
the upcoming discussions.
So let's jump in with the big questions
that might motivate one to read this
paper, this kind of paper, even if they
were not familiar with the authors or
topics.
And these are just a few ways to write it
up.
Of course, not the only ways.
So, first question how can we effectively
and efficiently navigate information
geometric or information theoretic
landscapes?
And how can we tackle that question from
an analytical, which is to say equation
based as well as a computational, which
is to say real implication based
perspective?
Often it's really fun, intuitive, natural
to talk about information theory, even
for those who haven't taken the technical
prerequisites.
And this work may help us navigate to a
space where we're able to think with good
intuitions about information geometry,
information theory, and also make sure
that those intuitions are going to be
caught by our technical tools.
Second, how can we optimize inference in
complexity models, including cases where
we are doing inference on action as a
parameter, also known active inference
lab?
Optimization and functional analysis, as
we'll come to see soon has long been
interested in these complex or
challenging models that are right at the
margin, right ant the border of what is
trackable or not.
Given the computational hardware that
modelers have access to, for example, big
data sets, high dimensional state spaces,
complex dynamics and so on, how about
cases where we're also interested in
doing parametric inference and
optimization on action or action plans as
a parameter?
Also known active inference lab.
And third, what technical underpinnings
support the rigor and applicability of
active inference and what special cases
are revealed when we consider
possibilities and constraints?
These are those two branches of
analytical and computational coming back
again.
We want to make sure that when we're
thinking within the active inference
paradigm, the active coherence ontology
is the language that we're speaking and
that there's a technical rigor to what's
being discussed.
Additionally, we want to make sure that
it's not just an analytical rigor, but
it's also going to be computationally
plausible tractable or maybe even
preferable.
That would be awesome.
Those are the questions that at least
appeared.
We are discussing this paper Geometric
Methods for Sampling, Optimization,
Inference and Adaptive Agents by Barp and
Costa at all shared first authorship and
it was published on active.
I'll just note a few key claims from this
paper.
They wrote Our goal in this chapter is to
discuss the emergence of natural
geometries within a few important areas
of statistics and applied mathematics,
namely optimization, sampling, inference
and adaptive agents.
That's the title.
We provide a conceptual introduction to
the underlying ideas rather than a
technical discussion highlighting
connections with various Fields of
mathematics and physics.
Well, I can tell you that they do make
connections with various Fields of
mathematics and physics, though.
Whether it is a concept introduction or a
technical discussion is all going to be
about your perspective.
Third, to illustrate a generic use case
for the previous methodologies that are
going to be discussed.
We consider active inference a unifying
formulation of behavior, subsuming
perception, planning and learning as a
process of inference.
So inference on adaptive agents is not
necessarily new.
It goes by reinforcement learning,
machine learning, and so on.
However, to use those methodologies in
the context of active inference a
unifying formulation of behavior is
something that the authors are bringing
forth here.
And last, we describe decision making
under active inference using information
geometry, revealing several special cases
that are established notions in
statistics, cognitive science and
engineering.
So active inference is not just unifying,
it's going to be shown to be generalized
as well.
Which is to say that special cases of the
generalization emergence different
formalisms that were known disparately
across Fields onto the abstract they
write in this chapter, we identify
fundamental geometric structures that
underlie the problems of sampling,
optimization, inference and adaptive
decision making.
Based on this identification, we derive
algorithms that exploit these geometric
structures to solve these problems
efficiently.
We show that a wide range of geometric
theories emerge naturally in these
Fields, foraging from measure preserving
processes, information divergences,
Poisson geometry, and geometric
integration.
Specifically, we explain how, one,
leveraging the symplectic geometry of
Hamiltonian systems enable us to
construct accelerated sampling and
optimization methods.
Two, the theory of Hilbertian subspaces
and Stein operators provides a general
methodology to obtain robust estimators
and three, preserving the information
geometry of decision making yields
adaptive agents that perform active
inference throughout.
We emphasize the rich connections between
these field e G inference draws on
sampling and optimization, and adaptive
decision making assesses decisions by
inferring their counterfactual
consequences.
Our exposition provides a conceptual
overview of underlying ideas rather than
a technical discussion, which can be
found in the references herein.
And indeed, there are several hundred
references in this paper.
Let's go to the roadmap.
So first we can start on the right side.
Here's an active agent room doing
accelerated optimization in the carpool
lane, looking ahead to the almost desert
like visual representation of active
inference.
That's where we're going to go.
And on the right side, it's just some
cars.
One of them is accelerated, the other one
isn't.
The paper begins with an introduction and
then in section two gets into the topic
of accelerated optimization covering the
areas of principle of geometric
integration, conservative flows and
symplectic integrators rate matching,
integrators for smooth optimization,
manifold and constrained optimization,
gradient flow as a high friction limit,
and optimization on the space of
probability measures.
In section three, they turn from
accelerated optimization in general to
Hamiltonian based accelerated sampling.
The subsections of three are optimizing
diffusion processes for sampling and
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo.
From the Hamiltonian based accelerated
sampling, they turn towards doing
statistical inference with kernel based
discrepancies.
In section four, the subsections are
topological methods for Mmds smooth
measures and KSDS the canonical Stein
operator and point Curray duality kernel
Stein discrepancies and score matching
information geometry of Mmds and natural
gradient descent minimum Stein
discrepancy estimators likelihood
coherence with generative models.
Finally, in section five adaptive agents
through active coherence, they're going
to bring it home to active inference.
Section five one modeling adaptive
decision making, behavior agents and
environments, decision making in precise
agents, the information geometry of
decision making.
And five two realizing adaptive agents,
the basic active inference algorithm
sequential decision making under
uncertainty world model learning as
inference and scaling active inference.
A quick note we have all the formalisms
entered Hinton our zero teams Coda
document.
There are 46 numbered equations in this
paper and 83 overall.
We're going to bring in some, but not all
of these formalisms in the dot zero
video.
And we're ready to bring in more during
the dot one one and dot two discussions
with the authors just for those who are
watching along.
I'm going to scan through all of the
formalisms from our Coda.
And again, for those who want to help get
involved with a dot zero preparation.
This is a little bit of what dot zero
preparation looks like.
I'm going to now scroll through the
formalisms just in case anybody wants to
screenshot or see them.
Great.
On to the keywords.
Keywords of the paper are information
geometry, hamiltonian Monte Carlo,
Stein's method, reproducing kernel
variational, coherence, accelerated
optimization, dissipative systems,
decision theory and active inference in
no particular pedagogical order.
Let's start with decision theory from the
Stanford Encyclopedia of Philosophy.
The article begins Decision theory is
concerned with the reasoning underlying
an agent's choices, whether this is a
mundane choice between taking the bus or
getting a taxi or a more far reaching
choice about whether to pursue a
demanding political career.
Decision theory is about agents making
decisions, cognitive things making
decisions.
And we can take a peek ahead to figure
three, which is shown here as well as
invoke some of the keywords that we're
about to walk into now.
So if this is your first time hearing
some of this vocabulary or you're super
familiar, either way, it's great.
In this paper and in this discussion,
we're going to see how different decision
theoretic settings such as no ambiguity,
no ambiguity or no coherence, no
extrinsic value and no intrinsic value
are going to be operationalized within an
information theoretic formalism an
information geometric formalism and
specifically one that we're able to do
accelerated inference on using
variational methods.
We're going to be involving action as a
parameter.
So we can call that active coherence and
that's how we're approaching decision
theory and getting from here to there
with all those fun stops in between.
Let's go to information theory.
The paper in the introduction writes of
particular relevance to this chapter is
information geometry, E g, the
differential geometric treatment of
smooth statistical manifolds whose origin
stems from a seminal article by Rao 23,
who introduced the Fishermetric tensor.
On parameterized statistical models and
thus a natural domain geometry that was
later observed to correspond to an
infinitesimal disturbance with respect to
the Kolback libelr or Kale divergence.
So going into citation 23 and 24.
Citation 23 is Rao from 1992.
And Rao wrote the objective of the paper
is to derive certain inequality relations
connecting the elements of the
information matrix as defined by Fisher
1921 and the variances and covariances of
the estimating functions.
A class of distribution functions which
admit estimation of parameters with the
minimum possible variance has been
discussed.
The concept of distance between
populations of a given type has been
developed, starting from a quadratic
differential metric defining the element
of length.
So I'm only going to give the disclaimer
one time.
Everything in red text is beyond
speculative.
It's just priming the pump for
discussions with those who know more and
with those who know less.
And it's just a first pass that we're
going to continue to develop on.
But broadly, if we can compute inequality
relationships, which this paper developed
in 1992, we can bound estimators, test
for relative improvements and basically
do stuff with those distinctions.
And if we can compute certain kinds of
statistical distances such that a
distance requires a length metric, we can
find optimal estimators of parameters,
specifically their variances and
covariance structure in principle and in
practice by finding that maximum
informational alignment to other
estimators or empirical data.
So we'll often say, like if you had the
radial parameterisation, you'd be
predicting as well as you could.
And so we want to be able to
operationalize that using distances and
metrics and citation 24 this is an
invariant form for the prior probability
and estimation problems by Harold
Jeffries.
And Jefferies wrote It has shown that a
certain differentiate form depending on
the values of the parameters in a law of
chance, is invariant for all
transformations of the parameters when
the law is differentiable with regard to
all parameters.
For laws containing a location in the
scale parameter, a form with a somewhat
restricted type of invariance is found
even when the law is not everywhere
differentiable with regard to the
parameters.
This form has the properties required to
give a general rule for stating the prior
probability in a large class of
estimation problems.
So if all the parameters in our model,
whether there's one, two or more, are
differentiable, which is to say they're
smooth, et cetera, et cetera, there are
technical details, then there are certain
transformational invariances.
So just like every Gaussian distribution,
by shifting it and stretching and
shrinking it, you can map those on to
each other.
It's like that.
It turns out that some of those
constraints can even be somewhat
relaxed.
For example, this approach may still be
effective even where parameters are not
differentiable everywhere.
And this is big for helping us do
Bayesian estimation, which can be seen as
a special case of informational
transformations or of manipulations of
statistical distributions in the
information theoretic or information
geometric sense.
Functional analysis.
So let's begin as tradition in our year
2023 with a brief quote from Chat GPT how
is functional analysis helpful for us who
are learning and applying active
inference?
I'll just read the last section.
Overall, functional analysis provides a
powerful mathematical toolset for
understanding and analyzing the
principles active coherence lab, and one
can read more.
Functional analysis is the study of
functions.
And here we see one way of showing what a
function does in terms of being this box
f of x that takes in an input, an
argument x and outputs a result y and
also that can be understood as a mapping
between or amongst spaces.
And there's a lot more to go into.
Just wanted to bring up that in math,
sometimes people have analyzed functions
and their properties and we're interested
in the properties of a special class of
functions, which are probability
distributions, well behaved probability
distinctions.
What do we do with those probability
distinctions?
Well, one thing we might want to do is
sample.
So the paper writes sampling methods are
critical to the efficient implementations
of many methodologies.
Most Modern samplers are based on Markov
chain Monte Carlo methods, which include
slice samplers, piecewise deterministic,
Markov chains and so on.
The original Hamiltonian Monte Carlo or
HMC, which we're going to get to
algorithm, was introduced in physics to
sample distributions on gauge groups for
lattice quantum chromodynamics.
It combined two approaches that emerged
in previous decades, namely the
Metropolis Hastings algorithm and the
Hamiltonian correlation of molecular
dynamics.
So the way that they state it in the
beginning of section three of the paper
is the purpose of sampling methods is to
efficiently draw samples from a given
target distribution row or more commonly,
to calculate expectations with respect to
row.
By equation 33 and other, they write,
Modern Hamiltonian Monte Carlo which
again we're going to get to in a second
relies heavily on symplectic integrators
another keyword to simulate a
deterministic dynamics responsible for
generative distant moves between samples
and thus reduce their correlation while
at the same time preserving important
geometric properties.
Now, we want to make our samples as
informative as possible.
If we're just foraging samples and it's
the same sample again and again, one can
imagine that it is uninformative.
Conversely, one can imagine a situation
where samples are informative and that is
brought into practice by making sure that
the samples are minimally correlation
with each other, as noted above.
And this also has analogy in
cryptography.
So if we're sampling something where the
successive samples are 99% correlated,
you can imagine that you're over
sampling.
So you're taking 10,000 frames per second
of a YouTube video with 30 frames per
second.
I think I'm streaming at 25 frames per
second right now.
Conversely, if one were to sample every
ten minutes, then their correlation
structure would also not capture the
videos 25 frames per second.
So in order to generate good and large
moves in the space, we would need perfect
knowledge of what the space is or how
it's generated, which is sometimes
knowable in cryptography, however
empirically, we need to use heuristics
and statistical approximations.
So this is the applied statistics angle
on the analytical relationships that
we're going to be talking about.
And it's going to come up again and again
this tension between analytical
formulations, what's true in principle,
and the statistical or numerical or
computational applications.
Two Hamiltonian Monte Carlo from
Wikipedia the Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
algorithm, originally known as hybrid
Monte Carlo still HMC is a Markov chain
Monte Carlo method for obtaining a
sequence of random samples which converge
to being distributed according to a
target probability distribution, for
which direct sampling is difficult.
So just a few first pass reflections.
We're sampling, which is to say Monte
Carlo.
And Monte Carlo is harkening back to a
different time when gambling was done in
Monte Carlo and the state space of all
the hands of poker were too vast to
compute analytically or equations were
not known.
And so what one used to do, and still
does, is draw samples and say, well, I
don't know if this is the final estimate
on how likely a royal flush is, but from
the 2 billion hands that I sampled, there
were two royal flushes.
And so it's one in a billion based upon
my sample.
So we're sampling because this is a
complex distinctions for which an
analytical solution is not possible, not
known, not relevant, or not trackable
computationally.
So there's various situations where we
want to sample and we don't necessarily
have an analytical solution.
When we're sampling from a converged
stationarity, hashtag live stream 26 of a
statistical landscape from a numerical
perspective, we understand that landscape
well enough to do coherence.
So imagine that we're sampling height
estimates from GPS locations in the X and
the y coordinates, and we're getting a z
value in our sample.
At some point we can say we're
unsurprised by new samples.
At that point we understand the landscape
well enough to do statistical inference.
And just like the frames per second in
the previous example, one can imagine if
the landscape is changing on the spatial
scale of 1 mile and you're sampling every
millimeter, you might be over sampling.
If you were sampling every league, maybe
you'd be too coarse grained with your
samples.
And so one reason that comes up in
science all the time for using sampling
is that the search space might be just
too large.
For example, the combinatorics of a
phylogenetic tree with a thousand species
might be vast.
And so it might be better to say
something like, well, 99% of the million
samples we drew were consistent with X,
because an analytical solution or a brute
force search, neither might be possible.
And the Wikipedia wrote this sequence of
samples can be used to estimate integrals
with respect to the target distribution.
So sometimes we're sampling not from the
target distribution itself, but rather
from a distribution that is related or
transformed from the target
distribution.
This is because sampling directly from
the target distribution might be
difficult or less than perfectly
informative.
So we might, for example, hint hint
sample from the derivative of the target
which might help us identify points
where, for example, the derivative is
flat in all directions.
In the case that we're sampling from a
derived landscape of the target
distribution, this is called a symplectic
integrator.
So let's look at what a symplectic
integrator is.
So first, backing up to what is
differentiate geometry.
Differential geometry is a mathematical
discipline that studies the geometry of
smooth shapes and smooth spaces,
otherwise known as smooth manifolds.
Symplectic geometry is a branch of
differential geometry and differential
topology that studies Symplectic
manifolds, that is, differentiable
manifolds equipped with a closed,
nondegenerate two form.
Symplectic geometry has its origins in
the Hamiltonian formulation of classical
mechanics, where the phase space of
certain classical systems takes on the
structure of a symplectic manifold.
So the keyword density is high.
These topics are all very closely linked
from the paper.
It has been known for a long time that
the class of symplectic integrators is
the preferred choice for simulating
physical systems, only the finest for our
simulations of physical systems.
These discretization techniques are
designed to preserve the underlying
symplectic geometry of Hamiltonian
systems and they also form the basis of
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo or hybrid Monte
Carlo methods.
We're going to come back to this tension
again and again, which is what good is an
in principle, smooth and differentiable
analytical correlation.
If our discreditization scheme, the way
that we actually implement the steps on a
computer, are inferior, we might ruin all
those nice properties that we work to get
about the analytical form.
We might just throw those out when we
discretize it coarsely or
inappropriately.
So what is the symplectic integrator?
It's a numerical integration scheme for
Hamiltonian systems.
Symplectic integrators form the subclass
of geometric integrators, which by
definition are canonical
transformations.
They're transformations we know a lot
about.
Symplectic integrator schemes are
referring to, again, just broadly, both
the analytical formulations and the
software packages and approaches that we
can use to implement those formalisms.
And these integration schemes are useful
across difficult estimation problems,
which is why they're used to study
nonlinear dynamics, molecular dynamics
like protein simulation, discrete element
methods, accelerator physics, plasma
physics, quantum physics, celestial
mechanics.
The time evolution of Hamilton's equation
is a symplectomorphism, meaning that it
conserves the symplectic two form.
A numerical scheme is a symplectic
integrator if it also conserves this two
form.
Let's hear more if this is not correct or
not complete.
But the one form is like the
differentiation and integration of a
line.
The two form is like the differentiation
and integration of a surface.
And the three form is like integration or
differentiate of a volume.
And John Denker has a great blog post on
the basic properties of a symplectic
integrator.
Some really interesting quotes that are
good to just keep in mind when we're
hearing about all these avenues we're
going to be exploring in the paper.
A symplectic integrator can serve the
area in phase space delimited by an
ensemble of systems.
For a periodic system, there is an area
that is conserved, namely the area inside
the phase space orbit of the system.
The main reason for mentioning the orbit
is to make the point that there are lots
of different things with dimensions of
area in phase space.
Some are conserved and some not.
Some are interesting and some not.
You have to specify which sort of area
you are talking about.
So another thing that's going to arise is
we're interested in very well behaved
outcomes from a very specific or
constrained, still broad, but definitely
constrained set of distributions.
For example, distributions that can be
interpreted in an information theory
sense as probability distinctions.
What was that mention of the Hamiltonian
and the shadow Hamiltonian?
So the author is right.
For symplectic brackets, which is the
kind of operation that reflects the
symplectic integrator, the existence of a
shadow Hamiltonian can be guaranteed
beyond the case of splitting methods, e.
G for variational integrators, which use
variational inference, which use a
discrete version of Hamilton's principle
of least action.
And we've heard it before that free
energy principle is a principle of least
action for inference and action and more
generally for most symplectic integrators
in which the symplectic bracket is
preserved up to topological
considerations described by some
technicalities that we can learn about.
As we shall see, such geometric
integrators can be constructed by
leveraging the shadow Hamiltonian
property of symplectic methods on higher
dimensional conservative Hamiltonian
systems.
In short, as a consequence of having
shadow Hamiltonian, such geometric
integrators are able to reproduce all the
relevant properties of the continuum
system.
These arguments are completely general.
So even before one knows what the shadow
Hamiltonian necessarily is, the authors
are letting us know that if we can
discretize the shadow Hamiltonian
appropriately through symplectic
integration, we can provide a inclination
scheme that ends up staying consistent
and compatible and all down the middle
with the analytical properties that we've
worked so hard to get.
And there were some different papers that
were cited and some that were found
during research.
This paper Time Step in Shadow
Hamiltonian and Molecular Dynamics
Simulations by Kim demonstrates
symplectic integrators on the simplest
possible system a simple harmonic
oscillator.
So if one wants to go to a technical
example, but one that builds intuition,
that's a great place to start.
And from the Wikipedia article on energy
drift, these integrators do not in fact,
reproduce the actual Hamiltonian
mechanics of the system.
Instead, they reproduce a closely related
shadow Hamiltonian whose value they
conserved many orders of magnitude more
closely.
The accuracy of the energy conversation
for the true Hamiltonian is independent
on the time step.
So if we can, for examples, just
metaphorically speaking, capture a high
evolution image of the shadow, then we'll
be able to know something, do something
with the actual some technical details on
Stein's method, which is a general method
in probability theory to obtain bounds on
the distance between two probability
distributions with respect to a
probability metric.
And Stein's method is used in the context
of Stein operators and Stein class, which
we're going to get to in the subsequent
discussions.
Reproducing Kernel our discussion of
inference builds upon the theory of
Hilbertian subspaces and in particular,
reproducing kernels.
These inference schemes rely on the
continuity of linear functionals such as
probability and Schwartz distributions
over a class of functions.
To geometrize the analysis of integral
probability metrics, which measure the
worst case integration error, we shall
explain how maximum mean kernelized and
score matching discrepancies arise
naturally from topological
considerations.
So we've added some background links here
to the slide, but it'll be a Brea place
to start with.
Authors, what is a reproducing kernel and
how is it used?
In this paper onwards, through the
keywords we go accelerated optimization
and variational inference.
So here's a 2016 paper from Michael
Jordan and other authors and some quotes
from the abstract.
Accelerated methods achieve faster
coherence rates than gradient methods,
and indeed, under certain conditions they
achieve optimal rates.
However, accelerated methods are not
dissent methods and remain a conceptual
mystery.
We propose a variational continuous time
framework for understanding accelerated
methods.
We provide a systematic methodology for
converting accelerated higher order
methods from continuous time to discrete
time.
Our work illuminates a class of dynamics
that may be useful for designing better
algorithms for optimization.
And this is going to be, again, something
awesome to discuss.
We've talked about, on many streams,
variational inference in the context of
gradient based optimization.
For example, the ball is rolling to the
bottom of the bowl, bottom of the hill,
and what you can do is you can take the
gradient div, grab curl and all that of
where the ball is and just go downhill.
And if you designed the hill to be the
right shape, or you're using a chosen
family of variational estimators that are
the right shape, are a good shape, well
behaved shape, then you follow the
gradient on down.
And that's how we've talked about
variational inference.
Accelerated optimization is going to be
accelerated from that.
And so it's fun to think about and it'll
be great to talk about.
Dissipative systems.
The vast majority of statistics and
machine learning applications involve
solving optimization problems.
The author is right.
Accelerated gradientbased methods and
several variations thereof have become
workhorses in these Fields.
Recently, there has been great interest
in studying such methods from a
continuous time limiting perspective.
Such methods can be seen as first order
integrators to a classical Hamiltonian
system with dissipation.
This raises the question on how to
discretize the system such that important
properties are preserved, assuming the
system has fast conversions to critical
point and desirable stability
properties.
Originally, such a theory of geometric
integration was developed with
conservative systems in.
Mind, while optimization in optimization,
the associated system is naturally a
dissipative one.
More recently, it has been proved that a
generalization of symplectic integrators
to dissipative Hamiltonian systems is
indeed able to preserve rates of
coherence and stability, which are the
main properties of interest for
optimization.
So from the Wikipedia on Hamiltonian
systems an example of a time independent
Hamiltonian system is the harmonic
oscillator.
So it's just a frictionless spring
oscillating around the Hamiltonian of the
system does not depend on time, and thus
the energy of the system is conserved.
And so we can say that that is a
conservative Hamiltonian.
If the Hamiltonian decays in time, it is
dissipative.
Recently, the advances of these authors
and others have extended our ability to
make distinctions of dissipative
Hamiltonians that respect the rates of
conversions and stability, which are the
main properties of interest for
optimization.
And we've talked about Hamiltonians on
Livestream number 49 with Dalton
Sakthivadivel Devil on Bayesian
mechanics.
So pretty cool.
What is conservative?
What is dissipative?
We'll explore as the final keyword here,
I just wanted to start with a blank slide
on active inference and see what happens
in 52.1.
So consider the slide to be blank and for
the authors and discussants looking
forward to hearing Hohwy.
Are we approaching active inference?
Given everything that we've just loaded
onto the table and everywhere that we're
about to go with the paper?
Let's get into it.
Section One introduction so, the authors
begin with differential geometry plays a
fundamental role in applied mathematics,
statistics and computer science,
including various domains.
Citations one through 22, which can be
shown here.
Various citations from this well cited
paper.
The geometric study of statistical models
has had many successes, ranging from
statistical inference, where it was used
to prove the optimality of maximum
likelihood estimator, to the construction
of the category of mathematical
statistics generated by Markov
morphisms.
So what are Markov morphisms from Ncat
lab?
The formalism of Markov categories can be
thought of as a way to express certain
aspects of probability and statistics
synthetically.
In other words, it consists of structure
and axioms, which one can think of as
fundamental in probability and
statistics, which one can use to prove
theorems without having to use measure
theory directly.
Intuitively, for the purposes of
probability, a Markov category can be
seen as a category where morphisms behave
like random functions or Markov kernels,
hence the name.
So, just some red text speculation.
It was a big success and a breakthrough
to think about the category from a formal
category theoretic perspective, to think
about the category of statistical
distinctions from an information
geometric perspective.
This means that we can understand many
analytical properties and transformations
of statistical distributions hashtag
Bayesian and develop general methods that
work for that whole category, like
accelerated optimization.
And the applications are vast.
Originally, such a theory of geometric
integration was developed with
conservative systems in mind.
While in optimization the associated
system is naturally a dissipative one.
Nevertheless, symplectic integrators were
exploited in this concept.
More recently, it has been proved that a
generalization of symplectic integrators
to dissipative Hamiltonian systems is
indeed able to preserve rates of
convergence and stability, which are the
main properties of interest for
optimization.
So, citation nine, what is it about 2021
paper on dissipative symplectic
integration with applications to gradient
based optimization by some of the
authors, and it's interesting to pull out
some quotes from the abstract and just
hear a little bit about what they're up
to.
Recently, continuous time dynamical
systems have proved useful in providing
conceptual and quantitative insights into
gradient based optimization widely used
in Modern machine learning and
statistics.
An important question that arises in this
line of work is how to discritize the
system in such a way that its stability
and rates of convergence are preserved.
So this is the sampling problem.
In continuum time, the math is continuous
and nice.
However, the sampling problem which
actually comes into play when we use
Modern computational methods that are
implemented on discrete time, space and
constraints, what happens when we use
unconventional computing?
That's an interesting discussion
question, but in active today, the
discretization approach is going to
matter a lot.
In this paper, we propose a geometric
framework in which such discretizations
can be realized, systematically enabling
the derivation of ratematching algorithms
without the need for a discrete coherence
analysis.
More specifically, we show that a
generalization of symplectic integrators
to nonconservative, and in particular,
discipline of Hamiltonian systems is able
to preserve rates of convergence up to a
controlled errors.
So this is the advance of this paper that
within a controlled error good enough,
they can model conservative and
nonconservative, even dissipative
Hamiltonian systems.
Moreover, such methods preserve a shadow
Hamiltonian despite the absence of a
conversation law extending key results of
symplectic integrators to nonconservative
cases, our arguments rely on a
combination of backwards error analysis
with fundamental results from symplectic
geometry.
We stress that although the original
motivation for this work was the
application of optimization, where
dissipative systems play a natural role,
they are fully general and not only
provide a differential geometric analysis
for discipline of Hamiltonian systems,
but also substantially extend the theory
of structure preserving inclination.
So they made this generalization.
In the case of optimization, however,
it's exciting that it extends even deeper
into the math and the symmetry.
Those are a few highlights from section
one on to section two.
Accelerated optimization vroom, vroom.
Here we go.
So there are going to be a lot of slides
from sections two through five, and to
keep the video a reasonable length, I'm
going to just highlight a few pieces.
Not even necessarily what I intended to
highlight, but I'm just going to go for
it so we can get through it.
Section two we shall be concerned with a
problem of optimization of a function
finding a point that maximizes V of Q or
minimizes negative V of Q over a smooth
manifold M r in the real numbers, many
algorithms and optimization are given as
a sequence of active inference.
Even when these algorithms are seen as
distinctions of a continuum system whose
behavior is presumably understood.
It is well known that most
discretizations break important
properties of a system, and they continue
to write.
The analysis of such finite difference
iterations is usually challenging,
relying on painstaking algebra to obtain
theoretical guarantees such as
conversation to a critical point,
stability and rates of conversation to a
critical point.
Even when these algorithms are seen as
discreditizations of a continuum system
whose behavior is presumably understood,
it is well known that most
discreditizations break important
properties of the system.
It can't be highlighted enough when we
implement optimization algorithms on
Modern computers, we have to make
discreditizations in space and time and
in practice.
So even if the analytical properties of
the distribution are totally fire, when
we try to solve and fit models to
empirical data, unless we also match that
elegance and power with a inclination
approach, we end up failing to realize
analytical promises.
2.1.
The principle of Geometric Integration
fortunately, the author's right here
comes into play one of the most
fundamental ideas of geometric
integrations.
Many numerical integrators are very close
exponentially in the step size to a
smooth dynamics generated by a shadow
vector field.
A little whisper of a shadow Hamiltonian
and the shadow vector field is a
perturbation of the original vector
field.
This allows us to analyze the discrete
trajectory implemented by the algorithm
using powerful tools from dynamical
systems and differential geometry, which
are a priori reserved to smooth systems.
So we're going to be able to discretize
our cake and have it be smooth too.
Crucially, while numerical integrators
typically diverge significantly from the
dynamics they aim to simulate, geometric
integrators respect the main properties
of a system in the context of
optimization.
This means respecting stability and rates
of coherence seems like a good idea to
respect the main properties of the
system.
This was first demonstrated in nine and
further extended in ten.
Our discussion will be based on these
work.
So citation Nine, Franca, Jordan and
Vidal mentioned previously and citation
ten, Franca, Mark, Girolami and Jordan
optimization on manifolds a symplectic
approach authors previous work So big
development we can use geometric rather
than course numerical integrators, so our
sampling based optimization schemes,
including their discordization, respect
the main properties of the system.
Sounds great.
Section Two Two conservative flows and
symplectic integrators as a stepping
stone, we first discussed the
construction of suitable conservative
flows.
These are very well studied and they're
very intuitive.
More intuitive.
To construct vector Fields along the
derivative of x, which is the function of
flows along which some function is
constant, we shall need brackets
geometrically.
These are morphisms x star to x, also
known as contravariant tensors of rank
two in physics.
So calling back the two form and the
brackets, importantly, vector Fields that
preserve f correspond to bracket vector
Fields in which B is antisemitic.
Constructing conservative flows is thus
straightforward.
Unfortunately, it is a rather more
challenging task to construct efficient
discretizations that retain this
property.
Most well known procedures, namely
discrete gradient and projection methods,
only give rise to integrators that
require solving implicit equations at
every step.
And they may break other important
properties of the system inclination.
96 this is the issue again.
No matter how nicely behaved in
principle, our analytical underlying
smooth differentiable function is if we
discretize it and we chop it up in a way
that's inappropriate.
We don't respect the properties of the
system, we don't end up with being able
to realize those analytical promises.
Indeed, in practice, the Hamiltonian
usually decomposes into a potential
energy associated to position and
independent of momentum, and a kinetic
energy associated to momentum and
invariant under position changes, both
generating tractable flows.
Thanks to this decomposition, we are able
to construct numerical methods through
splitting the vector field.
A few ideas coming together here,
recalling some of our generalized
coordinate based approaches to non
equilibrium steady states and Bayesian
mechanics, and also decomposition of
complex functions.
Note also that for symplectic brackets,
the evidence of a shadow Hamiltonian can
be guaranteed beyond the case of
splitting methods, eg.
For variational integrators, which use a
discrete version of Hamiltonians
Hamilton's principle of Least action and
for most symplectic integrators in which
the symplectic bracket is preserved up to
topological considerations described by
the first Dean cohomology of FaceBase.
So for discussion with authors annual
what are the splitting integrators?
What is split from what and why?
What is the bracket notation or
operation?
And what is a piss on bracket?
What is a piss on system?
Section 23 rate matching integrators for
smooth Optimization so, having obtained a
vast family of smooth dynamics and
integrators that closely preserve F, we
can now apply these ideas to
optimization.
What is being set up in this section and
why?
In equation seven we see that the damping
coefficient gamma of t being greater than
zero reflects the dissipative component,
or the second term in that right hand
side of equation seven.
So damping coefficient controls the
strength of the dissipation.
One can imagine that if the damping
coefficient is zero, the dissipative side
zeros out and b has conservative behavior
and so on.
So what is being set up here and why?
Dot dot dot dot dot the existence of such
a Leopold function described above
implies that trajectories starting in the
neighborhood of Q star will converge to Q
star.
So it's like a ball rolling to the bottom
of a hill, just like we've always
wanted.
In other words, the above system provably
solves the optimization problem minimum
of V on Q, such that Q is in the D
dimension.
Real punchline.
We're setting up a system with good
smooth optimization characteristics ball
rolling to the bottom of a smooth hill
that is also on the path or using the
notation of or prepared to make the
transformation to attractable
discretization approach.
So some more on the damping coefficient.
They bring up some common choices for the
damping coefficient.
And Big O notation describes on the order
of which something occurs.
For example, linearly order of the
variable or sub or super linearly as a
function of time or data points.
So in computational complexity analysis,
people are often interested as I double
the amount of data I'm analyzing, does
that make the algorithm take twice as
long?
That's linear computational complexity?
Does it take four times as long?
Does it take the same amount of time?
And so on.
And it'll be great to talk about the
intuitions and implications and
generalizations about how the damping
coefficient influences the computational
complexity estimates for convergence in
different settings.
They write the conservative system from
equation 16 reduces precisely the
original dissipative system 13.
The second equation in 16 reproduces 14,
and the remaining equations are
equivalent to the equations of motion
associated to 13, which in turn are
equivalent to eight.
As previously noted.
Formally, what we have done is to embed
the original dissipative system with
phase space r 2D, so real with 2D
dimension into a higher dimension
conservative system with phase space r 2D
plus two.
The dissipative dynamics thus lies on a
hyper surface of constant energy k equals
zero in high dimension.
The reason for doing this procedure,
called implication, is purely
theoretical.
Oh, come on.
It's not purely theoretical.
Since the theory of symplectic
integrators only accounts for
conservative systems, we can now extend
this theory to dissipative systems
settings by applying a symplectic
integrator to 13 and then fixing the
relevant coordinates 17 in the resulting
methods.
Geometrically, this corresponds to
integrating the time flow exactly.
We're going to talk about a relationship
between time and dissipative systems.
After all, it's dissipative systems that
are dissipating in time.
And so discreditization of time plays a
role in the appropriate inclination of a
dissipative Hamiltonian.
And in citation nine previously raised,
such a procedure was defined under the
name of presymplectic integrators.
And these connections hold not only for
the specific example above, but also for
general non conservative Hamiltonian
systems.
So what is happening here?
What's and intuition for conservative and
dissipative systems?
And how have the recent works of Franca
at all expanded what is possible?
We are now ready to explain why this
approach is suitable to construct
practical optimization methods.
The coordinate t sub k becomes simply the
time discreditization, which is exact,
and so is U sub k, since it is a function
of time alone.
Importantly, U does not couple to any of
the other degrees of freedom.
So it is irrelevant whether we have
access to U or not, because we're looking
to solve a function of t 17.
A can be substituted in 15 to get 18, and
you can replace 13 to get 19.
We'll talk more about it with the
authors.
Therefore, the known rates.
Equation eleven for the Continuum system
are nearly preserved, and so would be any
rates of more general time dependent
dissipative Hamiltonian systems.
Let us now present and explicit algorithm
to solve the optimization problem.
This is all happening as a consequence of
having a shadow Hamiltonian such that
geometric integrators are able to
reproduce all the relevant properties of
the Continuum system.
Section Two Four manifold and Constrained
Optimization following ten, we briefly
mentioned how the previous approach can
be extended in great generality to an
optimization problem.
So equation 21 we present our
minimization problem V of Q variational
distribution on Q.
Citation ten Franca et al.
They write There are essentially two ways
to solve this problem through a
dissipative Hamiltonian approach.
One is to simulate a Hamiltonian dynamics
on T star M by incorporating the metric
of M in the kinetic moving part of the
Hamiltonian.
Another is to consider a Hamiltonian
dynamics on RN and embed M into RN by
imposing several constraints.
The first approach uses a Lee group.
We'll talk more about it.
An example of a second approach one can
constrain the integrator on RN to define
a symplectic integrator on M via the
discrete constrained variational approach
by using some techniques.
The above method consists in a
dissipative generalization of the well
known rattle integrator from molecular
dynamics.
Citations 100 through 103 used in
computational biology.
Section Two Five gradient Flow as a High
Friction Limit let us provide some
intuition why simulating second order
systems is expected to field faster
algorithms.
As an illustration, consider figure one.
On the left, we'll look at in a second
where a particle immersed in a fluid
falls under the influence of a potential
force.
Negative delta sub q on V in Q.
So partial differential with respect to Q
of V on Q that plays a role of gravity
and is constrained to move on a surface.
So ball rolling down the hill.
We weren't joking about it.
In the underdamp case, the particle is
underwater, which is not so viscous, so
it has acceleration and moves fast.
It may even oscillate.
In the over damped case, the particle is
in a highly viscous fluid such as honey,
and the drag force that damping
coefficient gamma is comparable or
stronger to the gradient.
Thus the particle moves slowly since it
cannot accelerate during the same elapsed
time.
Delta T, an accelerated particle would
travel a longer disturbance.
Here's figure one.
So here y simulating second order systems
yields accelerated methods.
So on the left, constrained particle
falling in fluids of differential
viscosity.
Here on the left, we have the particle
falling through honey.
It's slowly making its way to the bottom
of the bowl, but it never really builds
speed.
Its terminal velocity is being dominated
by the viscosity of the fluid, whereas
this bowl falling through water or
falling through air is with respect to
the honey dampened bowl.
This is like an accelerated optimization,
and they present some numerical results
that help us bolster that intuition.
Really fun and embodied way to think
about optimization.
We've talked about that ball rolling to
the bottom of the hill and what the ball
does when it hits a small bump.
But we have not talked about what media
the Bull is floating through and the
media is the message and the fish doesn't
know what it's swimming through.
Section 2.6 optimization in the space of
probability measures.
It'll be great to explore more because
we're going to see free energy
calculations on the stationary density,
KL divergence and more.
For now, we can just say all those
optimization techniques we were bringing
up earlier, we're going to be able to do
them on information geometric spaces that
correspond to probability measures that
are well behaved.
Not all distinctions are probability
measures or probability distributions.
Just because you draw a line doesn't mean
you can use that in part of your
variational inference scheme.
For Bayesian statistics.
That's section two.
On to section three Hamiltonian based
accelerated sampling.
So we talked about the Hamiltonian
conservative and dissipative and the
shadow Hamiltonian, which is going to be
orders of magnitude better to
approximate.
We talked about gradientbased methods and
how accelerated sampling is going to help
us accelerate those sampling techniques.
And now section three brings it together
with Hamiltonian based accelerated
sampling.
Section Three the purpose of sampling
methods is to efficiently draw samples
from a target distribution row, or more
commonly, to calculate expectations with
respect to row.
And from the end of the paragraph.
An efficient sampling scheme is one that
minimizes the variance of the Monte Carlo
Markov chain.
Estimator Monte Carlo, that means that
we're sampling hands from the poker table
and Markov chain, which means that the
past only influences the future through
the present.
It's a quote memoryless process.
In other words, fewer samples will be
needed to obtain a good estimate.
Intuitively good samplers are Markov
chains that converge as fast as possible
to the target distribution.
It's like if you laid down a jump rope on
a mountain.
If that jump rope converged quickly to
the topography of the mountain, it would
have been a fast converging jump rope.
And we're doing something like that, but
with sampling from the jump rope.
3.1.
Optimizing diffusion processes for
sampling as many MCMC methods are based
on discretizing continuous time
stochastic processes.
The analysis of continuous time processes
is informative of the properties of
efficient samplers and diffusion
processes possess a rich geometric theory
extending that of vector Fields and have
been widely studied in the context of
sampling.
Lot of very fascinating ideas here.
Stratinovich stochastic differential
equations are going to come into play.
Equation 34 more technical details on
diffusion.
The calculus of twisted differentiate
forms allows us to have a measure
informed calculus on multivector Fields.
What are twisted differential forms?
I'm looking forward to that
conversation.
What is the untwisted differential form?
Have we been twisted all along or not?
And they go on to write a fundamental
criterion for efficient sampling is non
reversibility.
A process is non reversible if it is
statistically distinguishable from its
time reversal when initialized at the
target distribution.
So once the jump rope is lying flat on
the mountain, it's like in a position of
reversibility.
Mixing metaphors at will.
Here measure preserving diffusions are
non reversible precisely when some
cognition are met intuitively non
reversible processes backtrack less often
and thus furnish more diverse samples.
So if you're that ball rolling on the
mountain, you want to just plow forward
and whether you're going up or downhill,
you want to be sampling and making moves,
but you don't want to be going back and
forth because at that point it's not and
efficient sampling path.
It's well known that removing
nonreversibility worsens the spectral gap
and the asymptotic variants of the MCMC
estimator.
So time discreditization spectral gap in
dimension with linear coefficients, one
can construct the optimal non reversible
matrix a to optimize the spectral gap.
We can have well behaved parameters that
help us get at optimal discretization
schemes so that that shadow Hamiltonian
can be preserved when we do discretize it
during optimization, so that we can
respect the key properties of the
system.
However, there are no generic guidelines
on how to optimize nonreversibility in
arbitrary diffusions.
This suggests a two step strategy to
construct efficient samplers one,
optimize reversible distinctions
dimension and two and a non reversible
perturbation equation 36 citation 125
diffusions are manifolds.
Diffusion on manifolds are reversible
when certain things are the case, and
they're not when other things are the
case.
Equation 37 we got a triangle pointing
down and a triangle pointing up.
We're going to talk more about it.
Under damped Langevin dynamics combine
all the desirable properties of an
efficient sampler.
It is reversible, has degenerate noise,
and achieves accelerated coherence to the
target density.
So all of this groundwork is helping us
get to an analytical formalization that's
going to have the right kind of
properties so we can do that discretion
right on the shadow Hamiltonian, so we
can agent the accelerated optimization
done.
3.2 hamiltonian Monte Carlo a challenging
task consists of constructing efficient
sampling algorithms with strong
theoretical guarantees.
We now discuss an important family of
wellstudied methods known as Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo HMC, which can be implemented
on any manifold for any smooth, fully
supported target measure that is known up
to a normalizing constant.
Some of these methods can be seen as an
appropriate geometric integration of the
underdamped Langevin diffusion diffusing
down that hill.
But in simpler, it is in general simpler
to view them as combining a geometrically
integrated deterministic dynamics with a
simple stochastic process that ensures
ergodicity.
Equation 38 if we interpret the negative
log density v of q as a potential energy
a function depending on position q, one
can then plug in the potential within
Newton's equation to obtain a
deterministic proposal that is well
defined on any manifold.
As soon as the acceleration and
derivative operators have been replaced
by their curved analogues.
So what pulls the ball down the hill?
Or, if you're an instrumentalist, what
force describes the movement of the ball
moving down the hill?
Gravity, I think there's a John Mayer
song about it surprises like gravity.
It can be understood as the minimizing
force that pulls the ball down the hill
or describes the movement of the ball on
its path of least action down the hill.
How cool.
More discussion around 38 bringing these
ingredients together, we thus have the
following HMC algorithm given dot dot
dot.
We're going to compute a function
according to one, a heat bath, two shadow
Hamiltonian dynamics and three metropolis
correction.
That's the recipe.
We're bringing those ingredients
together.
The above Rudimentary HMC method was
proposed for simulations in lattice
quantum chromodynamics, with M being the
special unitary group Su N, and used a
Hamiltonian dynamics ingeniously
constructed from the Mauer carton frame
to compute the partition function of
discretized gauge theories.
This method has later been applied in
molecular dynamics and statistics.
There are three critical properties
underpinning the success of HMC in
practice.
The first two are the preservation of the
reference measure and the existence of a
conserved shadow Hamiltonian for the
numerical method.
The third critical property is the
existence of splittings methods, for
which all the composing flows are either
tractable or have adequate
approximations, namely the geodesic
integrators.
So geodesic methods buckminster, fuller,
tensegrity, cybernetics, or however you
think about geodesics as paths and curved
space.
That is the kind of approximation and
splitting we're gaining access to, with
appropriate distinctions on those balls
rolling to the bottom of the hill.
Let us also briefly mention some useful
upgrades that have been proposed in
recent years.
So for those who it's been a few years
since you checked in with this domain,
this is a great place to look.
First, you can grant the method extra
integration steps when the proposal is
rejected, or you can use criterion that
aim to ensure the motion is long enough
to avoid random walks, but short enough
that we do not waste computational
effort, such as the no uturn examples,
which is integrated in a lot of software
packages.
Second, Modern HMC methods bypass this
issue of slow convergence by replacing
the heat bath with an ornstein olbeck
process, which ensures the overall
algorithm is irreversible.
An ou process is like a Brownian
diffusion with a linear regression, so it
vibrates and has volatility, and it has a
trend line that's linear.
Third, many modifications of the
Rudimentary HMC algorithm only provide
improvements when the acceptance rate is
sufficiently high.
A third class of upgrades improve the
acceptance rate by using the fact that
the shadow Hamiltonian is exactly
preserved by the integrator big point of
the whole paper.
Finally, the metropolis step can be
replaced with a multinomial correction
that uses the entire numerical
trajectory, accepting a given point along
it according to the degree by which it
distorts the target measure.
Some path based inference methods with
some caveats all right, on to section
four statistical inference with kernel
based discrepancies.
So, section four the problem of parameter
inference consists of estimating an
element theta star within big theta using
a sequence of random functions or
estimators theta hat n of omega onto big
theta equations conveniently reproducing
Colonel Hilbert spaces.
RKHS are precisely Hilbert's spaces over
which the Diroc distinctions, which is a
statistical distinctions type where it's
like a spike at one location and zero
elsewhere, act continuously.
So whether we're talking about events or
spiking neurons, this is a really good
property.
And more generally, the probability
distributions that act continuously by
integration on an RKHS h are exactly
those for which all elements of h are
integral.
So analytically we have that nice
property denoting by fancy piece of h,
the set of such probability measures such
that dot, dot, dot, we can define the
maximum mean discrepancy, or Mmd, as such
more definitions, a practical expression
for the squared Mmd.
So just like in linear regression, we're
often interested in the sum of squared
errors.
Here we're interested in the sum of
squared Mmd.
4.1.
Topological methods for Mmds just
remember Mmds maximum mean discrepancy.
A key feature of RKHS is that there are
Hilbertian subspaces, more details about
embedding in Hilbert spaces and
subspaces.
The geometric Analysis the geometric
description of RKHS and Mmd allows us to
swiftly apply topological methods in
their analysis.
There are reasons this reduces the matter
to a topological question.
Instead of defining T star to be the set
of probability measures it is commonly
done to define statistical manifolds.
It's desirable to embed franca p within a
more structured space, such as the space
of finite radon measures, which enables
the method to learn the target function
independently of the data generating
distribution.
What is a radon measure?
We're going to find out.
However, it enables the method to learn
the target function independently of the
data generative distinctions sounds
pretty important if we want that tale of
two densities Mmd can discriminate
distinctions that makes it useful to do
other things.
Let's find out more.
Section 4.2 smooth Measures and KSDS So
more information on Mmds and about making
them computationally.
Tractable and citations to Stein's Method
are provided for 195, which is the 1972
Stein paper, and 196, which is a paper
written by some of the authors about
Stein's Method meets statistics.
A review of some recent developments from
2021, and I thought it'd be fun to look
at some figures from this paper and look
at the abstract, so I'll put the figures
up above.
Stein's method compares probability
distributions through the study of a
class of linear operators called Stein
operators.
While mainly studied in probability and
used to underpin theoretical statistics,
stein's method has led to significant
advances in computational statistics.
The topics that are discussed in that
review include tools to benchmark and
compare.
Sampling methods such as approximate
Markov chain, Monte Carlo deterministic,
alternatives to sampling methods, control
variant techniques, parameter
estimations, and goodness of fit
testing.
And from the paper they write the list of
results given in this paper are but a
mere sample of the ongoing activity in
this newly established area of research
at the boundary between probability,
functional analysis, data science, and
computational statistics.
For instance, Stein's method has been
used for designing sampling based
algorithms for nonconvex optimization
learning semiparametric multi index
models and high dimensions and Bayesian
statistics physics.
Stein discrepancies have been used as
variational objectives for posterior
optimization, which is what we're all
about free energy functionals, using
variational inference as objectives for
posterior approximation of inference and
action free energy principle.
And these images have some nice
intuitions too.
Here we see, depending on our step size,
we're getting different sampling.
When our step size is to the negative
fifth power, we're over sampling one part
of the space.
Then, as we make the step size larger,
our samples are drawn from different
distributions.
So that's selecting the step size epsilon
for a stochastic gradient Langvin dynamic
and also from the anastasio paper.
Here's another fun way to see that.
Here we have that bowl that we're rolling
the ball to the bottom of, and the Stein
points and the Stein thinning, which is
helping us understand maybe how starting
the ball in different locations or
critical locations accelerates what we're
doing with optimization.
So cool to talk about.
4.2.1 the canonical Stein operator and
Poincare duality there are two
fundamental theorems that help us
understand the integral differentiate
geometry of the manifold durham's theorem
and the Poncare duality.
The former Durham's theorem relates the
topology of the manifold to information
on the solutions of differential
equations defined over the manifold.
The latter, which contains the
fundamental theorem of calculus,
describes the properties of the integral
pairing alpha beta of differential forms,
which include the pairing of test
functions with smooth measures.
Let's learn more about it.
Four, two, two kernel stein discrepancies
and score matchings technical definitions
facilitating Stein variational gradient
descent.
4.3 information geometry of Mmds and
natural gradient descent.
These tools have proved to be useful in a
wide range of contexts.
More information about the divergence and
how divergence can improve the speed of
coherence by following the natural
gradient descent.
Okay, red text speculation beware.
So the operator, which is a phone routing
system like ring ring, hello, operator is
constructed in action.
4.2.22 colonel Stein discrepancies and
score matching you can't have a Ttest
without the T distribution.
The Ttest statistic is using a T
distribution.
So a class of fancy V, a set fancy V of
vector Fields, or more generally,
tensorfields whose image f under the
operator ring ring has mean zero under Mu
that's going to give us this discrepancy,
the SD and the Stein variational gradient
descent.
So there's some class of V vector Fields
such that the mean of something about
them is zero.
Does this enable the central limit
theorem or just statistics more broadly,
like the parametric and non parametric
methods that we know and love from SPM?
Does that mean zero enable us to use
Gaussian methods, generalized Gaussian
methods, generalized linear methods,
SPM?
And does it enable the proposed smooth
distribution, the one generating the
shadow Hamiltonian that's getting
inferred over, to be interpreted or used
truly as a statistical distribution?
It's easy to forget that not all
distributions are formal probability
distributions.
For example, the area under the curve
from zero to one of a probability
distribution is one.
Something has to happen.
But not all functions have an area under
the curve of one between zero and one.
So in variational Bayesian inference, the
kind which we do in active inference, in
fact, the kind that's done in machine
learning and statistics more broadly.
But we're interested when action is a
parameter that we're doing inference on.
We're concerned with the extremely well
behavior properties of a certain subset
of distributions.
So why are we doing this?
Why is it important that we didn't need
the input data that we could construct
measures that are independent of the
input data?
Because we want to enable the tail of two
density.
We want to make generative models that
can be used generatively, generative AI
in the forward or the generative
direction.
But we also want to be able to enable the
recognition distribution, which is from
empirical data, to do hidden state
inference.
And so just like least squares regression
in the linear modeling case, where the
sum of squares above and below the
regression line should be as low as
possible l two norm sum of squares
minimization always works, never
complains.
We want that kind of ball rolling to the
bottom of the hill with free energy
functionals variational and expected free
energy functionals as the optimized or
satisfied imperative for optimal
perception, which is signal processing,
signals intelligence and control which is
control theory or action selection.
More technical details and equations 39 B
and 39 C.
So what does it mean that the resulting
Stein discrepancy can be thought of as an
Mmd that depends only on row and is known
as a kernel Stein discrepancy.
What is that?
As we did previously, we can remove the
super mum by rewriting the above as a
super mum over some unit ball of
continuous linear functional.
Is this like simulating or modeling a
sphere rolling on a landscape like we've
been talking about?
Is the ball of optimal radius for rolling
on that landscape?
Or what is being optimized?
And what is the unit, the scaling or the
scale specificity that this scale
friendly sphere is scaled to?
Equation 42 and 42 a while in the
Euclidean space yields the diffusion
score matching.
Citation 204 Barp et al again minimum
Stein discrepancy estimators from 2019
they write the main strength of our
methodology is its flexibility, which
allows us to design estimators with
desirable properties for specific models
at hand by carefully selecting a Stein
discrepancy.
We illustrate this advantage for several
challenging problems for score matching,
such as non smooth, heavy tailed or light
tailed densities.
So again, just with a little bit of
speculation here and I think my camera
has frozen.
It's all good.
I'll just go without the camera.
Okay.
One can estimate infer or optimize the
zero point and hence the variance
structure of the distribution.
This is going to ensemble generalized
wellbehaved modeling again, from all of
those nice perspectives that we raised
earlier, like Gaussian central Limit
theorem, smoothness, statistical
disturbance, Euclidean, all of those well
behaved properties that we're looking
for.
This is going to help us get there.
We are only talking about a specific
subset or type of landscape here, the one
that we're doing variational inference
on, that's the map.
This is not the structure of the
territory.
These well behaved attributes of models
for better, worse and different through
sickness and health is because they're
maps.
It is always the case that our
statistically nice generative models are
of a different structure or form than the
generative process.
So this is actually not a criticism of
quantitative modeling as a process.
In fact, this is the entire basis of
quantitative modeling.
So we've approached this map territory
distinction.
Map territory fallacy, fallacy, fallacy
from many angles and one will still hear
things like well, the structure of the
statistical model is not the same as the
territory.
Or how can you say that the organism has
these well behaved properties just
because the model does?
And this brings a really sharp light on
it, which is we're doing this insane
amount of analytical groundwork so that
the map has the good properties not to
constrain what the territory is.
So map territory, all of the math we've
been talking about is map.
We want wellbehaved maps so that we can
describe wellbehaved and unruly
territories.
But it isn't the case that the organism
minimizes variational free energy.
It's the generative model that minimizes
variational free energy.
So, little bit of a leading discussion
topic or question for you all.
Feel free to give a thought in the live
chat or write a comment or join our
discussions.
How is this line of basic and fundamental
math research by Barp et al.
Creating new models that have the
operational or denotational semantics
that we want for computational
statistics, which is to say applied
information theory.
For example, distributions that can be
interpreted or used as statistical
distributions, ideally directly
compatible with current computational
methods SPM in MATLAB, Pi, Mdp in Python
and fourney Lab in Julia and so on.
Section 4.3.1 minimum Stein discrepancy
estimators, more technical details, more
inclination to 204.
The parameters can be adjusted to active
characteristicness consistency, bias,
robustness and obtain central Limit
Theorems C 204.
2019 paper with Barp et al.
And let's just look at a really cool
image from that paper.
Figure one and figure two pretty cool.
SD estimators looking nice.
Section 4.3.2 likelihood Free Inference
with Generative Models so for many
applications of interests, the densities
of the model mu sub data cannot be
evaluated or differentiated.
We thus need density free inference
methods super convenient for Bayesian
statistics, more technical details,
information tensor.
Under appropriate choices of kernels and
models, one can derive theoretical
guarantees such as concentration and
generalization boundary consistency
asymptotic normality and robustness.
So, little bit of a summary we have good
analytical and computational footing in
certain kinds of situations or under
certain constraints.
Certainly not all constraints, but
definitely for some that might enable the
efficient computation, not just
specification, but actual implementation
of large generative models such as
described in the paper of Friston et al.
2022 designing Ecosystems of Intelligence
from shared sorry.
Designing Ecosystems of Intelligence free
Energy Principle And they use the term
ecosystems of shared intelligence in that
paper.
And so it's relevant to learn about the
actuality and build intuition.
Why?
How do we know?
Well, here's the one figure in that paper
of Friston at all, the one figure in this
absolutely positional paper that they
have released believes as parameters of a
probability distribution.
Here's the sharpening of a belief as a
distance belief updating as traversing a
statistical manifold, which is to say a
lower dimension projected space and
what's being shown as the parameter space
of a probability distribution.
So whether we see this as gradient ascent
to climb to the top of the hill or we
take the negative and we have gradient
descent to the bottom of the hill, this
is the figure chosen by some very well
informed authors to describe Bayesian
mechanics.
And long last we get to section five
adaptive agents through active
coherence.
We close, as the authors write, with a
generic use case called Active Coherence,
a general framework for describing and
designing adaptive agents that unifies
all aspects of behavior, including
perception, planning and learning as
processes of inference.
By exploiting this geometric structure in
a generic framework for designing
adaptive agents, we derive the objective
functional overarching decision making
and describe its information geometric
structure, revealing several special
cases that are established notions in
statistics, cognitive science and
engineering.
So section five one modeling.
Adaptive decision making.
First, they're going to talk about
behavior, agents and environments.
Behavior is going to be defined as the
interaction between an agent and its
environment.
And the system is going to describe the
agent plus its environment.
There's going to be a set of states that
are partitions from a statespace big x
external states.
S are going to be unknown to the agent
and constitute the environment states
belonging to the agent.
Pi particular states are going to be a
subset of two different things.
So here is S, which is here external
states.
Note that in some other settings S will
refer to sensory states.
So look at the notation in this paper and
Pi, which in other papers is sometimes
used to describe policy inference here is
going to describe particular states.
So Pi is O and A.
O are the observable states, states that
the agent can see but cannot directly
control sense states and A are the
autonomous states that the agent sees and
can directly control.
And those are going to be internal states
and active states.
Figure two has a great representation and
again note the way that Pi, So and A are
being used in this paper.
S is the external process hidden state,
latent state, causal coherence.
O are the observations and the agent
process concepts of Pi, which is the
observations and alpha or A.
A is consisting of, according to the
particular partition, two different kinds
of states, which is internal states,
cognitive states and action states.
And so we're going to compute bounds for
free energy functionals with a special
focus on autonomous processes.
Because controlling our perception is not
possible, and maybe not even preferable
by controlling it at the level of what we
observe.
But rather, if we control our internal
states, which is our interpretation of
the perception and our action states,
we'll be doing optimal perception and
optimal action.
So those are the two sides of the coin
with inference as perception learning and
action selection.
That's how we unify action and
inference.
Inactive inference is by caring about the
bounding of selfsurprisal, just like
gravity on our autonomous processes.
So this will be super fun to discuss
more.
5.1.2 decision making and precise agents
so, what distinctions people from small
particles people are subject to classical
as opposed to statistical mechanics.
Check out Active Livestream 49 for more
on Bayesian mechanics and some of these
distinctions with classical statistical
quantum and thermo.
In other words, they are precise agents
with conservative dynamics.
Precise agent definition 5.1 an agent is
precise when it evolves deterministically
in a possibly stochastic environment.
More definitions and it's useful here to
highlight Friston et al's.
Recent paper path integrals particular
kinds and Lagrange things which provides
a taxonomy of things taxonomy of
particular entities that run the gamut of
sophistication from inert particles which
have no active states active particles
which have active states generative
process which have cognitive dynamics
that are described as classical and
strange particles which represent in this
visualization the highest level of
cognitive sophistication in which those
internal hidden states themselves have
this kind of what would happen if this
happens counterfactual type or thinking
through other minds type cognitive model
structure doing forward and inverse
inference on these great times.
5.1.2.
Decision making and precise agents we
have mathematical formalisms for
decisions, preferences and predictions
all using the partitioned variables.
5.12 more formalisms we get to expected
free energy.
Expected free energy is equation 41K.
Active inference is Hamilton's principle
of leased action on expected free energy
and expresses the most likely decision
where certain features are met principle
of least action on manifolds of inference
and action subsuming or bringing together
inference and action active inference,
free energy principle 5.1.3.
Active Inference Framework AIF looks like
it describes agents that engage in
purposeful behavior.
We can rearrange the expected free energy
EFE in several ways, each of which
reveals a fundamental trade off that
underwrites decision making.
This allows us to relate active inference
to information theoretic formalizations
of decision making that predominate in
statistics, cognitive science, and
engineering.
Figure three, as hinted ant in the early,
early keywords.
Here on the top, we have the general
formalizations of active inference.
And one of the partitions, or better to
say competition, is shown here, where
extrinsic value is the surprising about
observations, making sure that what we're
getting in observations are what we
expect slash prefer if the body wants to
be expecting homeostatic temperature.
That's what this is going to determine.
And it plays a role equivalent to reward
in reward and reinforcement learning
based approaches, because we don't need
to actually set a reward function, but we
get something that looks like
selfsurprisal aligned with reward using
the preference variable over
observations.
A lot more to say there.
And the second term is the intrinsic
value, the epistemic value, curiosity,
novelty, learning, reduction of
uncertainty.
And another partitioning is between risk
and ambiguity.
There are four colored dots red, tan,
gray, and Bleu corresponding to special
cases.
So under the setting where there's no
ambiguity, we realize or manifest the
special case where control can be seen as
inference, maximum entropy, reinforcement
learning, prospect theory, and KL optimal
control.
This is like doing as good as you can
strategically or tactically, given that
there's no ambiguity in how your
decisions play out.
Now, under the setting where there's no
ambiguity or preferences, a maximum
entropy principle is realized.
And work with Bayesian mechanics.
And Dalton et al.
Has shown that the constrained maximum
entropy principle is dual to the FEP in
the case of no extrinsic value.
So no quote reward, no quote goals.
We don't use reward or goals in the
active inference ontology, but borrowing
those words from some long, long
forgotten ontology, in the case of no
extrinsic value, we realized the special
case of maximum information gain,
Bayesian experimental design.
So not to prove or disprove, but the
maximally informative experiment that's
the Bayesian scientific epistemology
intrinsic implication and Bayesian
surprise seeking out optimally
informative stimuli.
And contrast that with a setting where
there's no intrinsic value.
So where there's nothing to learn, we
realize expected utility theory, Bayesian
decision theory, reinforcement learning,
and optimal control.
So special cases from many different
Fields, ranging from statistical
mechanics to Bayesian decision making and
statistics integrated or perhaps better
generalized across in the formalisms of
active inference, which is something like
a Hamilton's principle of least action on
variational or expected free energy,
expressing the most likely inference and
action under certain constraints.
Not the most rewarding, but the most
likely.
5.1.3.
Decision making minimizes both risk and
ambiguity.
Risk, first term on the right hand side,
ambiguity second, term minimizing
ambiguity leads to a type of
observational bias commonly known as the
streetlight effect.
When a person loses their keys at night,
they initially search for them under the
streetlight.
Because of the resulting observations, I
see my keys under the streetlight, or I
do not see my keys under the streetlight
accurately disambiguate external states
of affairs.
First place to look make sense under the
streetlight, and the last place you look
is where you find it more in.
5.1.3.
Decision making maximizes extrinsic and
intrinsic value another decomposition of
the formalisms of active inference
maximizing information gain leads to a
goal directed form of exploration driven
to answer what would happen if I did.
That true counterfactuals this decision
making procedure underwrites Bayesian
Experimental Design in Statistics, which
describes optimal experiments as those
that maximize expected information gain.
And we've had some great discussions
recently in textbook groups and in
discussion hours, where we contrasted
that falsificationist concept of accept
or reject hypothesis, and even the idea
of a scientist or a researcher setting
out to accept or reject hypothesis.
Whether you take that Positivist or you
take the other path of falsificationism,
in both cases, you might end up with an
informative experiment or not.
But you can easily imagine cases where
you end up with an uninformative
experiment because you set out to confirm
something you knew, or you set out to
disprove something by constraining your
experiment so that it was locally
disproven.
In contrast, when we take into account
the richness of our generative model, we
motivate this Bayesian epistemology and
ultimately professional Bayesianism,
where we make optimal experiments in
terms of their maximum expected
information gain, which requires you to
also state your generative model.
Decision making under active inference
weighs the imperatives of maximizing
utility and information gain, which
suggests a principled solution to the
exploration exploitation dilemma.
Great point to jump into.
Does active inference, simply by written
down, by being written down on a paper,
resolve or transcend or dissolve
exploration exploitation?
No.
Does it provide a space or a framework, a
method, an approach, software packages, a
research community that can help us
address and navigate and surf on the edge
of that dilemma?
Absolutely.
5.2.1.
The basic active inference algorithm
we're going to go through it with authors
preferential inference.
We want to infer preferences about
external and observable trajectories.
Two for each possible sequence of past,
present and future actions.
A we're going to engage in both sides of
the coin perceptual inference what would
I perceive if that happened?
And planning as inference assess the
action sequence by evaluating its
expected free energy.
And then three, decision making execute
the most likely decision at T plus one,
according to some distinctions, sample
from your action posterior, action prior
that's, like your habits, it gets
sharpened or modified with expected free
energy, and then you sample from the
action posterior.
5.2.1.
Sequential Decision Making under
Uncertainty a partially observable Markov
decision process POMDP is a discrete time
model of how actions influence external
states.
In a POMDP, each external state depends
only on the current action and previous
external state.
That's the Markov property.
Each observation depends only on the
current external state, and one can
additionally specify a distribution of
preferences over external trajectories.
One and two form the agent's POMDP
prediction model.
Two and three form the agent's hidden
Markov preference model, which defines
the active inference agent.
A simple simulation of active inference
on a POMDP is provided in figure four.
Implementation details on generic POMDPs
are available.
For more complex simulations of
sequential decision making, e.
G involving hierarchical POMDPs, please
see citations.
Figure four.
It's a prediction model.
This is sequential decision making in a
Team A's environment.
On the left, the agent's prediction model
as a POMDP, represented here as a
Bayesian network.
On the right, information on the team
A's.
So here we have some type of Bayesian
graph reflecting hopefully a statistical
system that's going to have all of these
well behaved properties that we've been
talking about in the paper.
And then the team AZ is played out.
We'll talk about it.
5.2.3.
World model learning is inference due to
a lack of domain knowledge, it may be
challenging to specify an agent's
prediction and preference model.
For example, how do external states map
to observations?
Should external states be represented in
a discrete or continuous state space?
Also, some great questions that come up
every day.
And Clark addressed in chapter six a
recipe for active inference modeling by
the Par Pazulo and Friston 2022
textbook.
So how do we get the right priors, or at
least approximately adequate priors?
One way to answer the question lies in
optimizing a free energy functional F,
which is an evidence lower bound.
We see here variational free energy
decomposed into an energy minus entropy
and decomposed into a complexity minus
accuracy.
Framing maximizing accuracy usually
results in generative models involving
universal function approximators
minimizing complexity results action
action oriented representation sparse
compartmentalized in hierarchical
generative models where higher levels of
the hierarchical model more abstract
representations, and vice versa.
A computationally efficient method to
compare priors by their free energy is
Bayesian model reduction, free energy,
unifies inference, and model selection
under a single objective function.
5.24.
Scaling active inference planning for all
possible courses of action is
computationally expensive.
One way to finesse this is by planning
only for intelligently chosen subsets of
action sequences using sampling
algorithms like Monte Carlo Tree Search.
If you're interested in that, check out
the recent research on branching time
active inference.
Similarly, Monte Carlo sampling finesses
the expectations inherent in assessing
action sequences.
A complementary approach is to assess
actions instead of action sequences by
conditioning all future actions to be
optimal in the sense that they minimize
the expected free energy.
It leads to smarter agents whose
computational complexity scales linearly
as opposed to exponentially in the length
of action sequence.
Let's learn more about it.
Scalable inference methods can be used to
make active inference more efficient.
We can train neural networks to predict
the various posterior distributions,
including the posterior over action while
training the output of the neural network
can be used as an initial conditions for
variational coherence, resulting active
inference whose computational costs
decrease as the network learns.
Additionally, optimizing free energy
reduces to efficient message passing
schemes when one imposes certain
simplifying distinctions to the family of
candidate distributions.
Lots of really exciting work in
neurobiology and statistics around
message passing getting close to the end
here a much cheaper implication of active
inference exists for continuous states
evolving in continuous time.
Pretty cool.
Par et al.
2022 Textbook Chapter Seven Discrete time
Active Inference generative Models
Chapter Eight Continuous time Active
Inference Models this method frames
perception and decision making as
variational inference by simulating a
gradient flow on free energy in an
extended state space.
It can be combined with discrete active
inference to operate efficiently in
generative models combining discrete and
continuous states.
We talked about that in live stream 46
Active inference does not contradict folk
psychology, discrete active inference
decision making, active inference dai,
and continuous time motor active
inference being used together, also seen
in the paradigm textbook.
As an example, high dimensional
observations in the continuous domain,
e.
G speech processed through continuous
active inference are converted into
discrete abstract representations, e.
G semantics, and we can even go further
and say rhetorical and narrative
information spaces based on these
representations, the agent makes high
level categorical decisions, eg.
I want to move over there, which
contextualize low level continuous
actions, eg.
The continuous motion of a limb towards
the goal location and that is how the
paper ends.
So, closing thoughts if anybody wants to
write a comment live, feel free to do
so.
We'll be over very shortly.
What are the implications of this work?
We have an open space to talk about it.
What questions and discussion topics are
you interested in?
Please write comments before or after the
dot one and the dot two so we can have
those interesting discussions.
And just as a little bit of a closer,
I'll share some stable diffusion images
that were generated using the paper title
as well as various other terms free
energy, lots of fun images, a lot of good
balance to some of the technical aspects
that were being described in the paper.
Was good to look at what diffusion looks
like aesthetically and so that is the end
of this Livestream.
52.0 I hope that you found it useful that
you're interested to act in first, serve
to learn more, contribute more, write a
comment, make it happen in your own life
or in your own way with this honestly
challenging paper.
So if you've listened this far, thanks a
lot for your attention and looking
forward to 520 One and Zero Two when we
will speak with some authors and some of
you.
So till next time, thanks again and see
you in the dot.
One.
Bye.